>> Will: BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
FAILING TO LIFT THE BAND BAN ON
TITLE 42 TODAY.
>> Ainsley: HISTORIC LEVELS.
NUMBERS OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS
REVEAL MORE THAN 1,000 ACROSS
THE BORDER IN 24 HOURS ONE
SECTOR ALONE WITH 23 OF THEM
EXPELLED UNDER TITLE 42.
>> Brian: RACHEL CAMPOS-DUFFY
TOOK A TRIP DOWN TO EAGLE PASS
IN TEXAS TALK TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEADERS AND SOME MIGRANTS.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
HEY, RACHEL.
>> Rachel: IT WAS REALLY EYE
OPENING.
FIRST OF ALL,GOOD MORNING AND
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I REALLY WANT TO THANK "FOX &
FRIENDS" FOR SENDING ME DOWN TO
THE BORDER BECAUSE IT WAS
EYE-OPENING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
SEEN TO UNDERSTAND IT'S
APPALLING THAT JOE BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS AREN'T LOOKING AT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
POLICIES AND ARE ACTUALLY
PURSUING APPEALING TO THE
BLOCKING OF TITLE 42.
LET ME SHOW YOU WHAT HAPPENED ON
THE TRIP BECAUSE I THINK YOU
WILL BE AMAZED AT THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY OUR GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T WANT US TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> Rachel: GETTING READY TO TAKE
OFF.
STATE TROOPERS FROM TEXAS TAKING
US UP OVER THE RIO GRANDE.
WHAT DO WE HAVE RIGHT HERE?
>> THIS IS A GROUP OF 130-PLUS
THAT JUST CAME ACROSS.
AT LEAST FIVE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS TIED UP PROCESSING ALL
THESE MIGRANTS THAT CAME ACROSS.
EXPOSES MORE VULNERABLE GAPS ON
THE BORDER.
>> WHAT ARE WE SEEING HERE LIKE
A MAKESHIFT TENT.
>> DEVELOP SOME OF THE
OVERCROWDING IN THIS SECTOR.
LIKE YOU SEE THERE, WHAT YOU SEE
AROUND IT IS A FENCE.
THERE IS SOME TYPE OF STRUCTURE.
GOES TO SHOW YOU THAT, YOU KNOW
THINK BELIEVE HAVING A BARRIER
IS PRIORITY OR VITAL WHAT THEY
ARE DOING HERE AS FAR AS THE
PROCESSING, BUT, YET, WE DON'T
SEE THAT ON THE BORDER WHERE
IT'S NEEDED.
>> Rachel: WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
AT RIGHT HERE?
>> PANELS FROM THE PREVIOUS
BORDER WALL THAT WAS BEING
CONSTRUCTED OF COURSE WE KNOW
THE BORDER WALL WAS CANCELED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
PANELS COULD BE USED FOR THE
BORDER WALL.
>> Rachel: AFTER GETTING A
BIRD'S EYE VIEW HE TOOK ME TO
GET A LOOK AT THE BORDER CRISIS
FRONT LINES RIGHT NEXT TO THE
RIO GRANDE.
>> THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE SEE
INCREASED ACTIVITY.
WE SEE ALL THE DIFFERENT
CLOTHING BEEN DISSCARREDDED,
SHOES AND DIFFERENT ITEMS.
>> Rachel: THIS IS SOMEONE'S
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
>> THIS WAS PUT UP BY THE STATE
TO STOP SOME OF THE CROSSINGS
THAT WERE TAKING PLACE.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS SOME OF
THE WET CLOTHING THEY USE IT TO
PUSH DOWN ON THE BARBED WIRE
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO CROSS OVER.
THIS IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
JOB TO SECURITY THE BORDER.
RIGHT NOW THE STATE OF TEXAS
HAVING TO BEAR THIS BURDEN BY
PROVIDING ALL THESE STATE
RESOURCES NATIONAL GUARDSMEN.
THIS IS STATE FUNDED OPERATION.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY BECAUSE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO SAFEGUARD THE AMERICANS,
SAFEGUARD THE BORDER.
>> Rachel: WHO CONTROLS THIS
AREA?
HONESTLY?
IS IT THE CARTELS.
>> THE CAFERTTLES THEY ARE USING
THAT MESSAGING AS FAR AS THE
BORDER IS OPEN TO ENCOURAGE
THESE MIGRANTS TO MAKE THIS
JOURNEY.
EVERY PERSON THAT CROSSES THAT
RIVER WHETHER IT BE A CHILD, A
WOMAN, FAMILIES, THEY PAY A FEE
TO THAT CARTEL.
>> Rachel: I SPOKE TO SOME
CUBANS INTERDICTED THIS MORNING.
EACH ONE OF THEM SPENT ABOUT
$12,000 TO THE COYOTES TO GET TO
THIS POINT RIGHT HERE BECAUSE
THEY ARE BEING ARRESTED.
>> Rachel: WE JUST SAW A GROUP
OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS CROSS OVER
HERE.
>> SO THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ANY BENEFIT WHERE HE COMES FROM
IS IF THEY WORK FOR THE
GOVERNMENT IN NICARAGUA.
>> SO I STARTED TALKING TO THEM.
THEY WERE WILLING TO GIVE ME AN
INTERVIEW BUT THEN THE BORDER
PATROL CAME AND SAID NOW YOU ARE
IN MY CUSTODY.
YOU CAN'T TALK TO THEM -- THE
MEDIA ANYMORE.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T WANT US TO KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON.
>> I HAVE BEEN SHOCKED BY THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY.
I DON'T BLAME BORDER PATROL.
>> THEY NEED TO BE TRANSPARENT
ON WHAT'S TAKING PLACE.
THIS EFFECTS EVERYBODY THIS
EFFECTS THE STATE OF TEXAS.
EVERY STATE NOW IS A BORDER
STATE BECAUSE OF THIS CRISIS.
>> PROBABLY ONE OF THE SADDEST
THINGS I HAVE SEEN IS THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE COMING ACROSS.
LITTLE LIFE JACKET RIGHT THERE.
OBVIOUSLY A CHILD'S LIFE JACKET.
THEY ARE MAKING THIS JOURNEY
WITH KIDS.
>>THIS IS MUCH MORE THAN
IMMIGRATION.
OF COURSE IT'S BORDER SECURITY,
NATIONAL SECURITY THE CHILDREN
COMING ACROSS AND HOW BEING
VICTIMIZED BY NOT JUST THE
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION BUT WHERE
DO THEY END UP.
>> Rachel: WE ARE STANDING IN
FRONTS OF THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS MIGRANT FACILITY FOR THE
ENTIRE DEL RIO SECTOR.
NOT EVEN THE MAYOR IS ALLOWED TO
SEE WHAT GOES ON INSIDE.
RECOMMENDATION WE HAD LOCAL
CHUNKS AND DIFFERENT THINGS WENT
OUT AND BOUGHT CLOTHES, FORMULA,
FOOD FOR THE KIDS IN THERE.
TRIED BRING IT WEREN'T ALLOWED.
>> THIS IS THE MOST
NONTRANSPARENT GOVERNMENT THAT I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
YOU SEE SECRETARY MAYORKAS, AND
HE HAS THIS GREAT ENTOURAGE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PEOPLE
FOLLOW HIM EVERYWHERE HE GOES.
GO STAY ON THE RANCH TWO MILES
FROM THE BORDER.
SEE WHAT THE COMMON ORDINARY
AMERICAN CITIZEN HAS TO DEAL
WITH BECAUSE OF YOUR LACK OF
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF THE
BORDER.
PARENT WON'T LET KIDS PLAY
OUTSIDE UNLESS ONE OF THE
PARENTS IS OUT THERE WITH A GUN
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
COMING BY.
>> YOU CAN'T HANDLE THIS AMOUNT
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION COMING
THROUGH.
>> WE CAN'T.
THEY PULLED MOST OF OUR AGENTS
TO GO OUT TO PROCESS.
THEY DON'T PLAN TO SEND THESE
PEOPLE BACK.
THEY PLAN TO PROCESS THEM AS
QUICKLY AS THEY CAN TO RELEASE
THEM.
THEY'RE NOT STAYING IN UVALDE.
THEY ARE PASSING THROUGH.
THEY ARE GOING TO YOUR
COMMUNITY.
GOING TO YOUR BIG CITIES.
GOING TO THE EAST COAST, GOING
TO THE WEST COAST AND TO MID
AMERICA.
>> Rachel: IT WAS JUST AN
INCREDIBLE TRIP.
SO EYE-OPENING.
I HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
LIEUTENANT AL VARES.
THIS LITTLE BOY WAS CAPTURED ON
THEIR CAMERAS.
WEIGHS ABANDONED BY THE CARTELS.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR HIM TO SEE
WHERE IS HE AT.
VERY COMMON, ONCE THE CHILD IS
OF NO USE TO THE CARTEL AND TO
THE GROUP THAT'S CROSSING OVER,
THEY ARE OFTEN JUST LEFT THERE.
THE MAYOR -- BY THE WAY, I HAVE
BEEN PRAYING ALL WEEKEND FOR
HIM.
HE IS THE SAME AGE, ACTUALLY
LOOKS A LITTLE BIT LIKE MY
LITTLE BOY.
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW HEART
BREAKING IT IS THE MAYOR OF
UVALDE TOLD ME WHILE HE CAN'T
GET INTO THE FACILITIES, EVEN
THOUGH HE HAS HAD CHURCHES
WILLING GO IN TO HELP THE
MIGRANT MINOR CENTER THEY WANTED
TO MINISTER TO THE KIDS.
READ TO THEM.
BRING TOYS.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
ANYTHING.
THEY ARE NEVER ALLOWED TO GET
FROM OR SEE ANYTHING.
THEY DO SEE OCCASIONALLY 11, 12,
13-YEAR-OLDS IN THE HOSPITAL IN
THE LOCAL HOSPITAL IN UVALDE
DELIVERING BABIES.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN ARE BEING
MISTREATED AND VICTIMIZED COMING
ACROSS THIS BORDER.
OUR GOVERNMENT KNOWS THAT AND
FRANKLY WE ARE ALL COMPLICIT IN
IT.
BECAUSE THIS IS HAPPENING.
OUR GOVERNMENT KNOWS IT THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO DO THIS.
THE TAKE AAWAY FOR ME FOR THIS
TRIP THIS IS NOT ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THIS IS ENTIRELY A PROCESSING
PROGRAM FOR OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
INSTEAD OF SENDING PEOPLE BACK.
THEY BUILD BIGGER PROCESSING
CENTERS MOVE PEOPLE THROUGH
QUICKER AND SEND THEM OUT TO THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Brian: RACHEL, REMAIN IN
MEXICO TITLE 42 IGNORING THE
POLICY.
TITLE 42 THEY HAVE ALREADY
TRANSFERRED IT.
ALREADY BASICALLY LETTING PEOPLE
THROUGH ANYWAY.
YOU GET HERE, YOU'RE IN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WALK AWAY FROM.
I ALSO, WHAT A GREAT REPORT YOU
DID.
AND TO SEE THAT.
>> Rachel: THANK YOU.
>> Brian: SEE THAT FENCE, THAT
WALL SITTING ON THE GROUND THAT
WE PAID FOR.
WE ARE PAYING TO STORE IT.
INSTEAD OF ASSEMBLING IT AND
PUTTING IT UP WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THAT WOULD HELP THE PEOPLE THAT
YOU WERE WORKING WITH TODAY.
>> Rachel: IT WAS SO INCREDIBLE
TO BE UP ABOVE IN THAT
HELICOPTER AND YOU SEE THIS NEW
TENT CITY PROCESSING CENTER
SURROUNDED BY A WALL BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WANT US TO
KNOW WHAT GOES ON IN THERE RIGHT
NEXT TO IT THE RUSTING TRUMP
WALL WHICH THE STATE OF TEXAS
OFFERED TO PAY FOR AND PUT UP
THEMSELVES.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAID
NO, WE JUST ARE GOING TO LEAVE
IT THERE RUSTING.
WE PAID FOR THE CONTRACT TO PUT
IT UP NO.
ONE IS WORKING.
THE WALLS ARE SITTING THERE.
>> Will: ALL RIGHT.
RACHEL.
GREAT JOB.
IT'S A GREAT PIECE.
IT TAKES US BEHIND THE SCENES
AND ONTO THE FRONT LINES SEEING
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
>> Ainsley: HOPEFULLY THEY WILL
FIND THAT LITTLE BITE BOY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE AS A MOM WHAT
GOES THROUGH THEIR HEAD JUST GO.
JU